[Music]
let me ask you a question
you think he black you think Tamir
people well they're not
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the streets are war zone
[Music]
you'll bloom now
I gotta mean to see a Stanek off
[Music]
listen you already got rid of everyone
that could talk the hell are you doing
here okay whoa whoa whoa whoa just relax
all cups here this isn't what it looks
get a body can't mine but we got a ghost
she's gone
inside you go breathe in here
let's get you out of here we got her all
he wants is the body camp
I've been shot what you can't be in here
with this the police they'll help it was
the cops they shot me
she cannot get back to the precinct to
upload the footage on that camera every
cop in criminal in this city is coming
to find her put everybody on him
[Music]
because a price on your head what you
gonna do
I'm a exposure
here is this
all that is B foot nothing
this missile playing we're still alive
on me
no choice to make right now one of us
he picked herself up
murders murder don't matter who you are
[Music]
you